imagine if you could predict the future
not perfectly mind you but with enough
accuracy that brilliant enough minds say
the best and brightest of the scp
foundation could plausibly reverse
engineer the main determinative factors
that caused a certain timeline to form
imagine if through carefully studying
these determinative factors the
foundation could carefully shape the
future into one that's more favorable
for the human race than all the
alternatives the preferred option if you
will would this not be advantageous your
next question is a very natural one
given the circumstances how does one
predict the future in such a manner well
the answer is uncomplicated but that
doesn't by any means make it easy you go
there spend a few months looking around
and then come back to report your
findings that's right folks we're not
talking psychics and seers here prepare
to expand your mind and please don't
worry if it all gets a little timey why
me because scp-2003
is the scp foundation's self-made time
machine even most of the staff at the
scp foundation itself don't know much
about
scp-2003 given the highly sensitive
nature of the projects surrounding it
much like scp-2000 is a trump card
securing our present in the case of a
catastrophic xk class end of the world
scenario
scp-2003 is our prophylactic for such a
thing happening in the foreseeable
future what's far more unique about
scp-2003
is that the scp foundation created this
ace in the hole from scratch the
scp-2003 time machine was invented over
a 25-year period by reverse engineering
the anomalous technology of three
different classified anomalies and
retrofitting them into our own
non-anomalous framework the massive
machine is housed in armed site-47 a
remote and well-guarded facility
disguised as an oil refinery while
extensive records of scp-2003's
construction have been made by the
foundation and it stands to reason that
the machine could be reliably and
successfully reproduced in a different
context even the most intelligent
scientists taking part in the project
couldn't explain how or why it actually
operates in the words of another mad
inventor it just works the operating
principle of scp-2003 are relatively
simple to understand it is able to break
the laws of the space-time continuum by
immediately transporting anything or
anyone placed in its central chamber to
some point in the chronological future
the subjects transported forwards will
remain in this future for several months
before instantaneously being transported
back to the exact location they were
standing in the future in order to
prevent some kind of unfortunate
accident like phasing back halfway
through a wall and becoming unpleasant
modern art the foundation has
established a secure facility for
travelers to head and wait out the rest
of their time when their mission is
complete through extensive testing
including that which was performed under
the purview of project xn shepard the
foundation has discovered a great deal
about the nature of time travel via
scp-2003
we'll outline the most crucial caveats
here so what happens next makes a lot
more sense to you after all if time
travel was easy everyone would do it
first as we alluded to earlier the data
collected by scp-2003 on the nature of
the future is often unclear imprecise
and unreliable for example the data
collected from 2003 did provide
extremely useful in predicting and
preventing a massive security breach
over at site 19 in 1997 so naturally
when it predicted a devastating series
of earthquakes off the west coast of the
united states in 1999 an event that
several agents sent through scp-2003
observed directly it came as a shock to
everyone when nothing happened the
foundation discovered following this
that all predictions needed to be
contextualized through heaps of metadata
for it to be of any real use in
predicting or preventing our specific
future the foundation also discovered
that certain individuals had a strangely
disproportionate effect on the unfolding
of future events let's say for example
scp-2003 discovers that a new type of
nuclear weapon will be invented in 2028
and quickly adopted by a number of
leading nations by 2030 and by 2035
tensions will rise sabres will rattle
and this nuclear weapon will be used on
mass to destroy human society as we know
it naturally in order to prevent this
the foundation might see to it that
certain groups of nuclear scientists
certain generals and certain world
leaders get liquidated and yet another
trip into the future shows that this
massive nuclear war was not averted but
why because it just so happens that this
event was inexplicably tied to the birth
of a little boy named james hoskins in
saskatoon circa 2025 despite little
jimmy hoskins seemingly having nothing
to do with the actual development of the
technology seeing as he's only 10 years
old when the bombs start falling the
foundation scientists working under
project xn shepard keep a database of
all these highly determinative
individuals also known as magnifier
individuals so they can keep tabs on how
they're affecting any future timelines
speaking of future timelines we're
afraid to tell you that this penultimate
caveat isn't exactly a pleasant one
there are few to any cohesive future
timelines where humanity survives long
term bummer right the foundation calls
these loose timelines determinative sets
and in the majority of them human
civilization collapses all humans die
and in some cases the earth becomes
completely uninhabitable to all forms of
life the foundation is currently seeking
a more optimistic option through
controlled manipulations of the casual
stream in our time but currently all we
have is the preferred option option xn
and if you're someone who would jump at
the chance to travel into the future and
take a gander at all the wondrous or
terrifying sights there's actually one
pretty major caveat of scp-2003
that we've been playing rather close to
the chest early foundation tests found
out that the time travel process via
scp-2003
is extremely damaging to plant and
animal tissue rather than just going on
a wacky time travel adventure like
doctor who or austin powers it'd be a
little more like stepping into a giant
microwave while dressed in a spacesuit
made of aluminum foil you're gonna die a
horrible death but there is one silver
lining well maybe not silver from your
perspective probably more like pewter
the foundation has discovered a way to
viably send human adjacent subjects
through time with scp-2003
without instantaneous death we just
can't promise that you're going to like
it you see the one kind of organic
tissue that seems to survive the
scp-2003 time travel process is the
human brain and nervous system due to
the highly controlled nature of project
xn shepard the foundation can't just
send in d-classes to do the job they
instead use actual agents though mostly
ones who are nearing or beyond
retirement or are suffering from a
terminal illness these agents are dosed
on a course of anti-anxiety
antidepressant and antipsychotic
chemotherapy to toughen their minds for
the horrors to come though the exact
nature of these horrors is kept secret
from them until it's already happened
you may be familiar with one of the
foundation's most well-known front
companies boston dynamics as well as one
of their most famous products the
robotic quadrupedal probe known as big
dog well in order to send a sentient
being through time without them being
completely destroyed by a cp-2003
the agent's brain and nervous system are
entirely removed from their body and
transported into the body of a modified
big dog still think it'd be fun to time
travel hey don't look so nervous for
everyone who agrees to be part of an
scp-2003 mission and survives you'll get
one hell of a pension or at least your
family will if that's any consolation
now that you understand all this let's
come clean about this mysterious project
xn shepard we've been alluding to
throughout the video it all started with
a letter to the heads of the scp-2003
research project from 05-7
a member of the legendary o5 council
that instructs the foundation in all
that it does the letter read up until
this point all attempts at future
intervention using scp-2003 have been
limited in scope and scattershot in
nature i have seen the wisdom in this
approach it is informed by painstaking
contingency planning and risk benefit
evaluation the past 18 months of reports
however have promise if you are bored
enough to seize the initiative we may
have found a way out here surprised so
there's our way surprised as you fell
now consider this note an official
change in policy as of today all efforts
at intervention are now aimed at
bringing about and preserving xn
designated magnifier individuals
associated this xn are to be protected
from undo interference at the expense of
all other priorities in particular
dyan must be allowed to die in the
manner most observations have predicted
for her if anything at all changes in
that regard make it happen i trust that
you're familiar enough with the rest of
the determinative sets to understand why
we're going this
so in short of all the potential
timelines 05-7 wants the researchers
assigned to scp-2003
to ensure that the timeline xn is the
one that actually comes to be
seeing as it's preferable to the
alternatives hence project xn shepard
you're probably wondering what happens
in timeline xn that makes it the most
desirable outcome possible well things
continue as normal everything from
anomalous activity to social unrest two
environmental factors stay pretty much
the same as time goes on until 2349 when
a giant 22 kilometer asteroid strikes
the earth and wipes out the majority of
humanity in an instant following this
the world becomes unfit for human
habitation hey don't look so glum you'll
all be dead by then well except dr
bright sorry again jack we at least get
a nice three centuries before we're
wiped from the cosmic table your next
question is probably if the preferred
option has humanity being wiped out by a
giant asteroid in a little over 300
years what are all the other ones aren't
we entitled to a multiple choice future
if we don't feel comfortable with being
completely annihilated by an asteroid
before we're even halfway to the year
3000 well we'll give you a little
tasting platter of potential timelines
and you can take your pick there was the
narrowly avoided scenario xb where
things progressed in a similar fashion
to scenario xn except a massive
gamma-ray burst from the sun in april
2017 wiped out all life on earth within
38 seconds then there's scenario xe
where the birth of an unnamed boy in
turkmenistan combined with the election
of sir william entwistle as prime
minister of new zealand in 2049 leads to
a world destroying nuclear exchange
between israel and greater indonesia in
2058 any attempts to stop it just make
it happen sooner or what about scenario
xh here a deadly mutated form of
influenza causes the deaths of over a
billion people worldwide combating this
threat causes increased cooperation
between world governments that actually
resulted in a huge net improvement for
global peace and quality of life it
seems unrealistic we know but scp-2003
doesn't lie however despite things going
well all known life on earth just
vanishes on july 29th 2059 it's a hell
of an unpleasant twist after things
start going so well for once in scenario
xo the anomalous increases in frequency
and magnitude in 2037 this leads to a
broken masquerade scenario where the
foundation's web of secrecy collapses
and anomalous chaos reigns across the
globe the foundation's members are
hunted and killed and world governments
attempting to weaponize the anomalous
leads to a new arms race that wipes out
all of humanity by 2048. or maybe
scenario xu is more your cup of tea in
this one the sun collapses leading to
eternal darkness and massive temperature
drops inexplicably humans still survive
but are in a state of constant unmoving
agony and maybe if you just really love
spiders you'll get a kick out of
scenario xx where a mysterious
pathogenic protist causes the majority
of humanity to fall in love with the
brazilian wandering spider one of the
few spiders that posed an actual threat
to humans the diverting of all resources
meant to keep humans alive to instead
breeding the spiders combined with many
many many many people being killed by
the resulting spiders leads to 6 billion
deaths in the early 2030s but hey you'll
get to see some pretty great spiders if
that's your thing i guess scenario xn is
hardly a picnic nobody likes the idea of
facing an armageddon straight out of
armageddon when that asteroid kills all
life on earth in 300 years but while it
undeniably isn't perfect it may just be
the best option we've got
isn't the future amazing now go check
out scp-2935
oh death and more epic scp stories you
can't miss and scp-999 tickle monster
versus the most evil scps for more
mind-blowing videos about the entities
of the scp foundation